[Musik]
hallo liefern wir machen heute ein
türkisches rezept viel habe ich
gewackelt ideen macht doch mal wieder
was türkisches dann habe ich mir gedacht
was ich mir oft super gerne stellen ist
tabu klatsch oder strom überall wird
anders geschrieben auf jeden fall ist es
ein sehr sehr leckeres gericht aus der
pfanne mit hähnchen mit peperoni
zwiebeln tomaten und ich werde es dazu
servieren dadurch dass das rezept so
schnell geht mache ich den reis jetzt
als allererstes und ich habe dazu zwar
schon videos und basic rätsel da könnt
ihr wirklich immer darauf zurückgreifen
und da habe ich auch die kleinen nudeln
mit dabei ist auch typisch türkisch aber
ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie ich dann
auf die schnelle ohne die nudeln machen
so das ist ein glas ist reicht immer für
hamza und milch und dann bleibt immer
auch was für nächsten tag übrig und
wichtig ist bei jetzt die gestärkt
heimat komplett raus zu spielen also
einfach unter lauwarmem wasser halten
nimmt dafür jemand sieht und dann so
lange bis das was da unten wieder klar
raus kommt
[Musik]
den gewaschenen reis dünnsten wir dann
noch in neutralem öl
es gibt einfach noch mal so nussiges
aroma und anschließend mit wasser
übergießen das ganze dann noch salzen
und sobald es einmal aufkocht den herd
auch schon unterscheiden stufe 2 oder 3
reicht da schon mit geschlossenem deckel
komplett durchgang das dauert so circa
18 bis 20 minuten und wir machen jetzt
schon weiter mit dem fleisch für unsere
fahne und da habe ich jetzt nicht nur
hähnchenbrust sie können natürlich
hähnchenbrust verwenden aber aus der
keule ist es einfach noch mal ein
bisschen saftiger und wichtig ist dass
jetzt sehr sehr sehr fein zu schneiden
also ich bin der persönlichen meinung je
kleiner desto besser
[Musik]
die hähnchen stücke habe ich jetzt schon
angebracht ich habe dafür neutrales
kokosöl genommen bzw sie können auch
neutrales fed nehmen sonnenblumen oder
rapsöl ich mag das ganz gerne weil es
einfach komplett geschmacksneutral ist
und ihr könnt damit auch super heiß
erhitzen und das brauchen wir jetzt auch
hier für meine haben wir zur ungefähr
drei bis vier minuten gebraucht ich
würde fast schon sagen drei weil ich
sehr klein sind und es geht nicht dass
forschung was dann jetzt gebe ich da
knoblauch mit dazu ich presse meinen
knoblauch immer könnt ihr natürlich auch
fein hacken und gleichwertig in der
zwischenzeit auch schon mal meine
zwiebeln richtig schön feinschneiden
peperoni und tomaten tomaten müssen
nicht ganz so klein sein aber die ganze
schnitzel arbeit kann man dann schon mal
erledigen und ihr könnt auch schon salz
und pfeffer zentimeter zu geben es kommt
zu vergleichen ein bisschen salz mit
dazu zum abschmecken aber vorab gerne
schon mal würzen
[Musik]
das macht ihr euch hier platz in der
mitte und dann die zwiebeln und die
peperoni einfach noch mal richtig schön
23 minuten lang mit andünsten
[Musik]
die tomaten habe ich jetzt noch mal dazu
gegeben ihm merkt auch dass die sagt
richtig austritt es wird alles so ein
bisschen flüssiger und weniger an der
stelle einfach noch weiter köcheln
lassen aber wir können auch ruhig schon
mal im nach spalten gerne auch nach
pfeffern und was ich ganz gern mag ist
einfach nur oregano ich bin oregano
passt super super gut zu den tomaten
wenn ihr lieblings gewürzt haben thymian
mit wenn ihr könnt ihr das dazu geben es
ist nicht mehr ganz so typisch aber ich
finde man kann ja ruhig nochmal seine
lieblings gewürzt mit ein spiel
einfließen lassen
das essen ist fertig der reihe ist es
auch fertig und ihr könnt wenn ihr
möchtet dann noch so ein bisschen butter
mit dazugeben ich persönlich mag das
ganz gerne mutter ist geschmacksträger
und schmeckt einfach noch mal richtig
gut im reis und da reicht es wirklich
wenn ihr das direkt rein gibt die
restplätze erledigt den kompletten rest
also ich werde jetzt einfach nur deckel
drauf geben fünf minuten warten und dann
einmal kräftig umrühren
[Musik]
ich habe mir jetzt mal gedacht haben so
wie mache ich mein test ganz kurz für
die zuschauer wäre sich auf die idee
gebracht das zu machen das was du
jetzt
hatten wir diese zwei tollen kupfer
fahnder die einem wirklich so krank
sind da
abgestimmt lassen und nein kommen wir
tauschen
würden sich gerissen du willst mir
vorher wo leute sind lächerlich machen
bitte schön bist du hast echt sehen von
dem mini baby das muss ich aber auch das
muss ich aber auch historienmaler kennt
die deutsche dem restaurant war so etwa
fünf jahre zuvor fotos machen dann
probieren wir mal gern
mit reis und es ist ein sehr schnelles
rezept muss ich sagen wenn ihr parallel
kocht braucht ihr vielleicht 25 minuten
wo ich kann erst getroffen werden wenn
wir als hersteller also sehr sehr zart
das falsche superzeit tomaten kommt raus
wie findest du es kann man so darf das
von meiner präsentation haben mir kein
mensch versuch betroffen
sind auch richtig lecker zufrieden
okay ich hab zwei stück rain geben aber
vielleicht könnte ja aber ich muss doch
sagen also damit dass die original als
wir das aber ich muss sagen es ist immer
scharf wird es draußen ist ja dass so
viel geworden ist das angießen wird ich
kann immer sagen nicht ganz so scharf
aber wir sind auch welche wir mögen das
nicht zu schaffen
also wenn es noch schärfer mit gibt auf
jeden fall mehreren aber ich habe
sowieso alles ganz genau wir bis jetzt
neben mir ja ich schreibe euch alles und
nelly infobox genau das finden nicht den
letzten video
habt ihr heute ein für alle mal haben
sie immer wenn ich zum infobox part
gerufen oder weil ich
sehe dass hier das muss etwas machen das
ist ja noch nie gemacht eigentlich zu
hause und jetzt hast du dass du kannst
du trauen also leute macht unbedingt
nach und könnt es euch zum mittagessen
bleibt freunde ein kommt alles zusammen
und
klar
jede mutter schwiegermutter und um
europa also ihr lieben ich mache den
richtigen trainer für mich und ich kenne
meinen auch noch also bis zum nächsten
mal tschüss
[Musik]